square continues to serve our community
rocky caught up with them about their
golden groceries program for seniors
lisa welcome to las vegas now oh thank
you so much for having me
of course you guys do such great work at
three square let's talk about the golden
groceries program
yeah absolutely it's a supplemental
grocery program for those that are 60
and better as we like to say
and it offers lean proteins whole grains
and fresh produce
and it really focuses on the higher
quality of nutrition that we know that
older adults need
i like that older or better yes for sure
how does food insecurity affect our
senior population here in southern
nevada specifically
yeah actually we um before covid we had
over 30 000 uh
60 plus people in our community that we
knew that we that needed help
and that we're hungry and so and we
don't even know what the number is
really now
that it's coveted happened and so with
the ever rising cost of housing and lack
of affordable housing here
you know seniors oftentimes after they
pay for their uh their
rent or their mortgage they have to make
that decision do i pay for my medication
or do i
pay for food and we don't want those
people making that decision nobody
should have to make that decision
so we oftentimes hear from seniors who
are on our program that this equivalent
of getting sixty dollars back in their
pocket so they're able to afford those
medications and essential items like
toilet paper
oh that's amazing and and what does what
separates golden groceries program from
all of the other services and programs
you guys provide
that's a great question but really
honestly it's just the uh the age factor
we really wanted to build a different
program
that was client choice meaning if you go
to any of our locations there's over 30
around town
and you get to pick your items not
everybody has the same you know medical
complications and stuff like that if you
want the peanut butter take that
if you don't want the oatmeal don't take
that and take something else and so we
really
it was really developed for seniors by
seniors the um the whole program was
that's so helpful i wish we could do
this for any age i know
personalized shopping list that's great
how do seniors actually get access to
the golden groceries program so we have
a call center here at three square the
phone number 702-765-4030
and you just call that number and our
caring advocates do all the screening
from there
so whether you need delivery because
home delivery is available there's
curbside options
we offer lift rides we've partnered with
lyft and
um so any option is available and we
take it from there and by the way on
lift there's no
smartphone or cell phone needed you can
actually call from a landline and we
schedule it in real time
you guys got everything covered
we tried there's no other qualifications
such as income medical history
immigration
status or anything like that so if you
just have to be 16 better
there we go easy as that well thank you
so much lisa thank you to three square
for all of the work that you guys are
doing
yeah thank you for having me today
appreciate it
three square food bank for more
information call 702-765-4030 or visit
threesquare.org
las vegas now we'll be right back